america's inflation surge continues a
new report shows prices on everyday
items jumped in june with the largest
increase in more than 40 years it's
hitting one particular group the hardest
[Applause]
[Music]
amazon has a catchy song to promote its
annual prime day which offers thousands
of deals
[Music]
[Applause]
but the sale comes as the cost of living
hit a sour note consumer prices jumped
9.1 percent in june the largest increase
in four decades a look inside the
numbers shows the cost of rent rose at a
rate not seen since 1991.
prices at the grocery store saw the
largest one-year increase since 1979
and gas soared nearly 60 percent in the
month of june it really impacts lower
household incomes much more dramatically
than anyone else
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger says the high prices are
making it difficult for many americans
to make ends meet don't forget a lot of
americans have used the excess savings
that they accumulated during the
pandemic stimulus checks unemployment
benefits there is a bit of good news the
cost of gas is dropping aaa says price
is down almost 40 cents a gallon in the
past month but drivers like joanne ward
tell us it still costs too much to fill
up i mean any little bit is good but
we could be paying a whole lot less
the federal reserve expected to once
again raise interest rates later this
month in an attempt to ease price hikes
but there will not be an immediate
effect it can really lag so the impact
of those rate increases takes a while to
trickle through the economy schlesinger
says inflation may not start to ease
until the fall